blotti dans l'hiver au bord de la loire
le domaine de chaumont est loin d'être
endormi le public profite de se calmer
vernal pour découvrir le château connu
pour ses jardins
chaumont sur le plan architectural
j'étais fasciné franchement
intérieurement je veux bien sur le plan
du travail accompli par des ouvriers
certainement toi tu consonance manuel
avec d'élevage heures et tout ça je
m'imagine pas le temps que ça du maître
pour faire un truc comme ça je suis sûr
qu'aujourd'hui on ne va pas leur faire
pour attirer plus de visiteurs en hiver
c'est la deuxième année que shum on
organise une grande exposition photos
des paysages l'extrême de juliette agnel
au travail de l'américain robert charles
man sur la trajectoire du soleil en
passant par les grands formats d'heinlex
mclean spécialement réalisé cet été pour
les 500 ans de la renaissance
le visiteur peut passer un long moment
au chaud en se laissant guider par les
artistes et leur regard sur le monde
pour réunir les expositions de
photographies à l'automne et à l'hiver
pour donner plus de visibilité à ces
artistes qui photographient des lieux
liés dont toujours à ce thème de l'art
et la nature
l'exposition dure jusqu'à fin février le
visiteur peut en profiter pour flâner
dans le jardin d'hiver un lieu apaisant
où il est invité à s'asseoir pour rêver
et penser au milieu des plantes mises à
l'abri jusqu'au printemps